you show up at a party and everybody's
like hey some guy is here in yellow and
I'm like it's Pikachu and they're like
barely and I'm like thank you today
we're trying on sexy childhood ruining
costume so basically sexy versions of
things for babies some things just
aren't meant to be sex it's for children
yeah we're gonna give some people some
confusing boners watches the cartoon was
like yep I want to dad I mean I was
sexually awakened by cartoons I don't
think anyone wasn't everywhere they're a
nightmare Oh minions these gays is so
funny they're like fire hydrants right
you can't ruin a childhood that's still
happening it's got a chinstrap it's it's
frightened they feel stretched out has
never been nice ooh as a tight minion
off to a good start
oh what a stick if anyone does the
minion voice in this I'm going to be
very upset
oh no are these guys like evil isn't
that the thick glass in there whoo
they're just little pill bugs that hump
they're like super sexually driven this
honestly isn't that dishonest of them I
don't know we're 20 forward anymore
this wouldn't ruin my childhood it would
titillate my childhood Oh anything
yellow that resembles them they want to
get time for a childhood ruining couples
costumes a mall pretzel vendor costume
candy stripers where do those go ah is
there such a thing as camel toe for guys
it's called moose knuckle
oh no it is so horrible it's like a mean
librarian I think I'm more of an earning
I don't think you're fitting into these
shorts no offense no I hold that just
scared that duck on the butt rubber duck
is so close to rubber dick I'm hiding
the letter D I love couples costumes
usually go with my wife but make an
exception exception this would be really
good as a sexy gay couples costume yeah
it doesn't make any sense you were here
let's adjust it yeah it's like what up
let's each other
hiya Bert Ernie you smell like liquor
I don't think bird ever really liked
Ernie he like pate de Mille ah I might
as well have an openly gay very sexual
couple on a Sesame Street they already
have entire fists up there but anyway so
all right they're puppets
oh boy I know this tale I had a Game Boy
Color Pikachu is a fearsome character
cuz he's fast but also powerful you're
making me a sexy Pikachu that allow
cartoon animals our free game to make
sexy I'm sorry I don't care who you are
oh I feel so neg this isn't a costume
it's tubes oh this is a man costume
we're sexy men now talked a lot today
about sexualized lady costumes but guys
also feel pressure to look good
everybody look at my body
I'm Pikachu or whatnot let's all
masturbate together
I think Pokemon more fun to dress up as
an in trainers because then you can be
creative figure she's preteen his voice
hasn't dropped yet this is a sexy 12
year old this is the cutest thing ever
I'm a conceptual electric rat come into
my cage pika pika this is a whole nother
meaning of the word Smash Brothers take
a [ __ ] pika you all want a baby rats
be my guest
on a sexy baby rat you can I'm glad I
can turn some grandmas on oh I get to be
Cinderella blue Oh me oh no I'm Belle
does that mean my wife is the Beast
I get to be a villain ha ha ha right now
I'm a mermaid if you were wearing a
thong this would be a seriously kinky
costume oh damn it's getting some
dominatrix [ __ ] fairy godmother made my
dress out of a dishtowel did not show
this much leg
I'll tell you that much that is a titty
hole come on can only wear this till
midnight sucking more I can't I have a
ribcage like a normal person why enter
from the bottom gotta do the bow you
could fit some boobs in here it makes
sense to sexualize Disney characters
oftentimes the sexiest characters are
the villains I am talking boom there
buddy Boppity boo this is like a cheap
trashy version of a beautiful ball gown
googoo gaga boys I feel like I'm a
condom I'm the belle of the ball I just
wish they give me enough fabric to cover
up this Biddle pumper it's gorgeous
you want to buy too this poison apple
Mia Mia on the wall
show me the try guy who's kidding as
pale as cottage cheese hair cover the
body like a rabid beaver
Cinderella's whole objective is I got
one night to find a man why not
Halloween have you fun costume if I had
my friends dresses like sexy
winged creatures I sing and they come on
my arm so I feel like we ruined a lot of
people's childhoods today I mean look at
me
this is clearly a mistake you love your
body and you like showing it off
yes sexy as you want just don't do it
when there are kids around if a
three-year-old owns pajamas with this
character on it you shouldn't be wearing
it sexy for Halloween like come on don't
come on me happy Halloween
we're sorry ah we've done worse but this
certainly isn't helping anybody
ah it's so stiff scissors fell we
Halloween